[Music]
in philip k dick's novel the androids
dream of electric sheep we encounter a
number
of these androids passing themselves off
at least at some time in the novel as
human beings many of them revealing that
they actually are androids and perhaps
the most interesting of them and the
most
central
to the workings of the novel is rachel
rosen
who is in a different position than the
escaped androids or even the harness
bull
uh the officer who is not going to be
targeted by deckard but is still you
know going to be suspect rachel rosen
will assume a
greater and greater role
within the novel to a culmination
in late in in the novel in chapters 15
and 16.
so we first encounter her at the rosen
corporation
up in seattle where rick deckert as now
chief bounty hunter has been sent by
inspector bryant why to make sure
that the voigt camp empathy test is
going to
work on these new nexus 6 androids who
are you know the top of the line and
seem to have some possibility of fooling
the test he also has to make sure that
the test is not going to be sweeping up
humans who lack empathy for whatever
reason
in the process so they go to the rosen
association and he's going to encounter
rachel rosen and have a little bit of
you know a chit chat with her about
animals and you know where they get
their stuff she's also expressing
a sort of hostility towards the police
departments on behalf of the rosen
corporation and she's being passed off
as
eldon rosen's niece alden rosen is a
human we think
and
he is you know in charge of the
corporation as much as anybody can be in
charge in this as we're gonna see
there's there's a very interesting
insight that deckard has
and he is going to put her forward
as the recipient of the void camp test
before that though let's look at what
happened so he lands the police
department hover car
on the roof of the rosen association
building in seattle he found a young
woman waiting for him black-haired and
slender wearing the new huge dust
filtering glass as she approached his
car her hands deep in the pockets of her
brightly striped long coat she had on
her sharply defined small face an
expression of sullen distaste right
dealing with these cops dealing with
their
nonsense and much much later we get
another description of you know what she
actually looks like um she you know we
get this
uh
here we go rachel's proportions he
noticed again were odd with her heavy
mass of dark hair her head seemed large
and because of her diminutive breasts
her body assumed a length almost
childlike stance but her great eyes with
her elaborate lashes could only be those
of a grown woman
there the resemblance to adolescence end
ended rachel rested very slightly on the
four part of her feet and her arms as
they hung bent at the joint the stance
he reflected of a weary hunter of
perhaps the cro-magnon persuasion the
race of tall hunters he said to himself
no excess flesh a flat belly small
behind a smaller bosom rachel had been
modeled on the celtic type of build
anachronistic
and attractive
so
quite quite interesting he's you know
the total impression was good
except for the restless shrewd eyes all
right now he's going to give her the
voigt camp test
and what we see is she fails it
and then eldon rosen says
well
clearly the voigt camp empathy test is
unreliable
because she's a human being
and
they start going back and forth and
rachel rosen is taking part in this
attempt to to bribe rick deckard to get
him
uh turned to get that him working for
them they offer him what turns out to be
a mechanical owl they're actually saying
that it's a real
owl that not all of them have died
and he's going to um you know try to
work with them on this he
almost cuts a deal
but what we find
is that
he's actually going to catch her
at the very end
in
this lie right how does that happen
he says
here we go i want to ask you one more
question from the voigt camp scale sit
down again rachel glanced at her uncle
he nodded and she grudgingly returned
what's this for
and he says my briefcase
nice isn't it department issue well well
she said remotely
baby hide rick said he stroked the black
leather surface of the briefcase 100
genuine baby hide he saw the two dial
indicators gyrate frantically but only
after a pause he says thanks miss rosen
that's all she says you're leaving he
says yes i'm satisfied and then she says
well what about the other nine subjects
because they're supposed to be testing
it on 10 of them and he says well the
scale's been adequate in your case i can
extrapolate from that it's clearly
still
effective and then he says to eldon
rosen does she know
sometimes they didn't false memories
have been tried various times generally
the mistaken idea that through them
reactions to testing would be altered
and then eldon rosen says
no we programmed her completely but i
think towards the end she suspected and
then to her
you guessed when he asked for one more
trial pale rachel nodded fixedly don't
be afraid of him eldon says you're not
an escaped android on earth illegally
you're the property
of the rosen association used as a sales
device for prospective immigrants he
walked to the girl put his hand
comfortingly on her shoulder at the
touch the girl flinched and then rick
says he's right i'm not going to retire
you miss rosen
good day
now
this is a cover
as it's going to turn out she she does
know that she's an android
this is not a
big surprise for her so we can ask
what's what's actually going on here
there's a very interesting thing that
rick is going to realize about the
rosen association now in in chapter
four
um this
he says it this way the senior rosen's
nervousness boyed up his own confidence
they're afraid of me he realized with a
start rachel rosen included i can
probably force them to abandon
manufacture of their nexus 6 types what
i do during the next hour will affect
the structure of the operation
it could conceivably determine the
future of the rosen association here in
the united states in russia
and on mars the two members of the rosen
family studied him apprehensively and he
felt the hollowness of their manner by
coming here he had brought the void to
them
he had ushered in emptiness and the hush
of economic death
they control inordinate power he thought
this enterprise is considered one of the
system's industrial pivots the
manufacture of androids in fact has
become so linked to the colonization
effort that if one dropped into ruin so
would the other in time the rosen
association naturally understood this
perfectly
eldon rosen had obviously been conscious
of it since harry bryant's call so we've
got this massive powerful organization
that is at the same time for this moment
vulnerable
to him and he's going to notice
something else
in chapter five
he could not make out even now how the
rosen association had managed to snare
him and so easily
experts he realized a mammoth
corporation like this it embodies too
much experience it possesses in fact a
sort of group mind now notice what he
says next
and eldon
and rachel rosen consisted of spokesmen
for that corporate entity his mistake
evidently
had been in viewing them
as individuals
it was a mistake he would not make again
so eldon as ceo is
not really an individual
rachel rosen also
is an individual and yet not an
individual there's this paradoxicality
to it that is going to come up later on
when she is discussing priss
and how hard it's going to be
for deckard to retire her
now a little bit later after this
exchange rachel rosen actually
calls uh rick deckard up um this is in
chapter eight
and uh rick says all right what do they
want as far as he could discern the
rosens had already proven to be bad news
and undoubtedly would continue to be so
whatever they intended rachel rosen's
face appears on the screen hello officer
deckard are you busy right now or can i
talk to you go ahead he says
we have the association notice we
have been discussing your situation
regarding the escape nexus 6 types and
knowing them as we do
we feel you'll have better luck if one
of us works with you in conjunction with
you by doing what he asks well by one of
us coming along with you when you go out
looking for them
why what would you add he asks rachel
says the nexus sixes would be wary at
being approached by a human but if
another nexus 6 made the contact
he says you specifically mean yourself
yes she nodded her face sober i've
already got too much help already
but i really think you need me i doubt
it i think i'll think it over and i'll
call you back and he hangs up and he
says um
that's all i need rachel rosen popping
up through the dust at every
step so she offers help and he turns it
down for the time being
then
later on much later on in chapter 15
he's going to finally
call her
this is after
you know three of the androids have been
killed uh
first him killing one and then him and
phil rush phil resh kills
the police inspector garland and phil
rush actually does kill libel luft and
and now
rick deckard is in a bad way he actually
takes the voigt camp test himself and
realizes he started to feel empathy
for some androids at least for
certain types ones that he can not
identify with but at least feel
something towards and phil resh the
other bounty hunter after he's been you
know proven to be human says listen
buddy this is basically sex
you know you get attracted to one so
have sex with them then kill them you
know that's how you can take care of
this and deckard
that guard is is moving in a different
direction so he he calls her
up
she appears on the video screen and he
says are you busy right now or can i
talk to you as you said earlier today it
did not seem like today a generation had
risen and declined since he talked to
her last
and all the weight all the weariness of
it had recapitulated itself in his body
felt the physical
burden and
she she says i told you without me one
of the nexus 6's would get you before
you got it he says well you were wrong
but you're calling anyhow do you want me
to come down there to san francisco and
he says yes come down tonight
and she they go back and forth she's
like ah it's kind of late you know
um
i i i it's an hour drive they haven't
had dinner and so he tells her you know
oh okay you're just being androidic
vengeful right because i tripped you up
on the voigt camp scale
and um
she says i can tell you really don't
want to do this job tonight killing the
last three androids maybe not at all
are you sure you want me to make it
possible for you to retire the three
remaining androids or do you want me to
persuade you not to try and he says come
down here we'll get a hotel room
and she says why he said something i
heard today about situations involving
human men and android women come down
here to san francisco tonight and i'll
give up on the remaining andes we'll do
something else so she she flies down and
they meet in the hotel room and they're
going to have conversation and then some
sex and then some more conversation
and we actually learn a lot
in what's going on and
rick's
feelings that are shifting within him
are also
coming to light so one of the things
that we learn
is that one of the androids that has to
be retired pris
is actually the same model
as rachel is the same nexus 6 type as
she calls it and this produces a kind of
not empathy as such
but rather identification
and rachel actually says you know we're
not
really individuals i'm just a type and
you know when when i die maybe priss
would step into my spot and take over
and we know that pris actually called
herself
rachel rosen earlier in the book when
introducing herself to isidore before
she
changes her tune so that's a an
important thing right there
and uh rachel then reveals why she came
down
was it just to
you know enjoy
time with with him and she says um
here's what's actually going on
and he she says do you know why i really
came here why elden and the other rosens
the human ones wanted me to go along
with you and then rick says
to observe to detail exactly what the
nexus 6 does that gives it away on the
voigt camp test now that's kind of a
unlikely thing because she's not going
to be watching him giving voigt camp
tests so she says on the test or
otherwise
everything that gives it a different
quality and then i report back
and the association makes modifications
of its zygote bath dns factors and then
we have the nexus 7. so this is part of
a continual improvement program
you could say
she is there to give her corporation the
rosen
association
a better
idea about where
the androids betray themselves as not
being
human and so she says
and when the when the nexus 7 gets
caught we modify again eventually the
association
has a type that can't be distinguished
and rick says do you know about the
bonnelli reflex arc test and she says
we're working on that too you know
someday the bonnelli test will fade into
yesterday's hoary shroud of spiritual
oblivion right
and it's interesting what he he said or
what dick says at this point deckard
could not discern her degree of
seriousness a topic of world shaking
importance dealt with facetiously an
android trait possibly he thought no
emotional awareness no feeling sense of
the actual meaning of what she said
only the hollow formal intellectual
definitions of the
separate terms right
and
so now she's come clean right she was
going to help out you know it's going to
be very good for her to come along now
she's actually part of this this you
know
quality
improvement uh pattern and she seems to
be on his side right she shows him a
device that will
incapacitate any android so if ray roy
beatty who deckard is most afraid of
bursts in on them he can he can freeze
roy beatty and then laser him
she um
you know makes a deal with him she says
okay you know i'll take care
of the most difficult one i'll kill
priss for you you can have the bounty
you just have to have sex with me you
just have to make love to me and she
actually tells deckard
i love you in fact she does it kind of
jokingly and she says that
um
you know if here we go if i entered a
room and found a sofa covered with your
hide i'd score very high on the voight
camp
test right
and she says go to bed with me and i'll
retire stratton okay because i can't
stand getting this close and then not
and rick is grateful as we see thank you
he said gratitude undoubtedly because of
the bourbon rose up inside of him
constricting his throat two he thought
now i only have two to retire would
rachel really do it and she says god
damn it get in bed so they have sex and
then afterwards they you know they order
some coffee they're laying around
enjoying the afterglow
and then rachel
reveals the real reason right this
quality enhancement thing wasn't the
real reason just helping out wasn't the
real reason
what is this about this is about
turning him
in a way that that they weren't able to
with bribing
she's able to
arouse
feelings within him that are going to
incapacitate him
as a bounty hunter so
here we go she he says um
this is my end he said to himself as a
bounty hunter after the babies there
won't be any more not after this tonight
you look so sad rachel said putting his
hand out he touched her cheek you're not
going to be able to hunt androids any
longer she said calmly so don't look sad
please no bounty hunter has ever gone on
rachel said after being with me except
for one a very cynical man phil resh and
he's nutty he works out in left field on
his own
and
she reveals that she knows the androids
that he's hunting
and then
[Music]
deckard says i doubt if it works as
often or as well as you say and she says
well it has with you
and he says well we'll see
and she says i already know when i saw
that expression
on your face that grief i look for this
and he asks well how many times have you
done that she says
seven or eight no actually nine
and the only one the only bounty hunter
who's come through this
having you know sex with me having his
emotions directed towards me as an
android and then been able to go on and
hunt is phil resch all the rest of them
had to
hang it up
and so he says
you know i think i'll kill you
um and she like tries to go for her
laser tube can't find it in her purse
and then sort of gives in and there's
this this interesting
uh here thing here um
the dark fire waned the life force out
of her as as he had so often witnessed
before with other androids the classic
resignation mechanical intellectual
acceptance of that which a genuine
organism with two billion years of the
pressure to live and evolve hagriding it
could have never reconciled itself to
and you know she says please just you
know make it painless
and he says well i can't do it
i'm not going to kill you
and
she ends up saying you've gone the way
of the others the bounty hunters before
you each time they get furious and talk
about killing me when the time comes
they can't actually
do it so she is going to get dropped off
and deckard is going to go on
and kill the remaining three androids
and it sounds like that's the last part
of the story but there is actually kind
of a
denouement that will happen
near the end of the book
it's in a very short chapter chapter 20
which is only two pages
rick deckard is is coming back after
having eliminated the androids he's
reported into his boss he lands on his
roof
of his apartment building his wife erin
meets him on the roof
she looked at him in a deranged peculiar
way in all his years with her he'd never
seen
her like this
and he says ah it's over i've been
thinking mary maybe harry bryant can
assign me to and then she says rick
i've got to tell you something i'm sorry
the goat is dead the goat that he had
bought with
or at least began buying putting on
installment with the first three
bounties that he had been paid
now notice what happens next for some
reason it did not surprise him it only
made him feel
worse a quantitative addition to the
weight shrinking him from every side and
he says well if it gets sick and she
said no i didn't get sick
something horrible happened somebody
came here
got the goat out of its cage
dragged it to the edge of the roof
and pushed it off he said yes she nodded
and he asked did you see who did it i
saw her very clearly barbara was still
up here fooling around he came down to
get me and we called the police but by
then the animal was dead and she'd left
a small young looking girl with dark
hair and large black eyes very thin
wearing a long fish scale coat she had a
male pouch purse and she made no effort
to keep us from seeing her as if she
didn't care
no she didn't care he said rachel
wouldn't give a damn if you saw her she
probably wanted you to so i'd know who'd
done it he kissed her you've been
waiting up here all this time only for
half an hour that's when it happened
half an hour ago aaron gently kissed him
back it's so awful so needless
and then
he says not needless she had what seemed
to her a reason
an android reason he thought
so you know not only displaying a lack
of empathy
but a sort of vindictiveness on her
part because he you know she actually
says you love that goat more than you
love me or your wife or anything else
and that's the last that we hear of
rachel rosen we know she's got about
another two years to live
at most as a nexus 6 android
and she might continue on trying to
eliminate further bounty hunters we
don't we don't really know she leaves
the story at that point but this is one
of the most interesting
depictions
of an android in this great novel to
android's dream of electric sheep
you